Kelsey ballerini is getting more candid
than ever in her in the new music of her
latest album subject to change yeah
shortly after the release on Friday one
song in particular started raising some
eyebrows as Kelsey appeared to reveal
that she and Halsey are no longer
friends after teaming up on her 2020
song the other girl the fourth track on
her previous album Kelsey
that's right so in Kelsey's new song
doing my best she hints at the broken
friendship singing I was friends with a
pop star I put him on track four but I
wish I could take it back I would have
never asked if I knew we wouldn't talk
anymore so it didn't take long for the
internet detectives to put two and two
together that the unnamed pop stars
Halsey
but she had to address the new track
because Kelsey recently spoke on
odyssey's Rob and Holly show admitting
it's not meant to be a shady lyric
can I tell you about this the lyric I
was analyzing and you can choose not to
talk about it because it sounds gossipy
and dramatic
it's called The song is called doing my
best right right that song is that song
is the song so yeah here we go is it is
it not because I don't it says a pop
star
the Halsey track four is that Halsey
is that no I mean I did put the track
number so the intention behind that
lyric because I do feel like I have to
say this is like it is not meant to be a
shady lyric it is meant to it is the the
whole idea of that song Just because
that song is going to be a song that
people talk about and I know that sorry
is
um no no no no it's I put it out
it's it's the idea of taking ownership
of my cringe it's just like I I wanted
to acknowledge all the things that
people have watched happen in my life
and just go yep yep here's the messiness
I own it I'm doing my best
uh Paul Wright he says why do people put
their beef on blast like this because
all musicians do it and
your loves your lost your angers right
yeah but I think that it's it's
incredible to hear um somebody have
regret about putting somebody on an
album on that album right like that's
the story that's new to me no yeah yeah
I I you know me I love I love feuds I
miss feuds I think that that too many
people are too nice
um to not air their pettiness I don't
like when people legitimately you know
hate each other I don't find that to be
entertaining right but I love pettiness
and for and for her to turn around now
and say I didn't mean it to be Shady
that to me is just Peak pettiness right
I'm going to say this but you wouldn't
have said anything oh of course you did
yes okay so Kelsey has previously said
her new album is all about welcoming
change when it comes uh including her
recently announced divorce from her
fellow country singer Morgan Evans yes
after sharing the news of their divorce
last month she changed the lyrics a few
of her songs during a concert stop in
New York City over the weekend while
performing her new ballad what I have
Kelsey changed the lyric I got a warm
body in bed too I got my own body okay
get over yourself instead of singing I'm
the crazy ex that wrecked your life she
uh belted I'm the crazy
um that wrecked your life what do you
think about all this so she has to
change everything
but I think that you adapt on the fly my
thing is is that it's incredible when
fans hear those changes when somebody's
doing it live because you know what it's
like to hear somebody love you it's like
you can't understand like you can hardly
hear anything but but for people to pick
those out you know that she hammered
those home right like she made it like
so the audience would understand
perfectly what she was saying again me I
love the shadiness of this oh my gosh I
I sort of do she's going through some
things she is fair to say that she's
going through a lot of things and she's
put it on this album and we're all here
for it yeah
justify everything right once you write
music about somebody else or about a
relationship that's going to be the
conversation that she's gonna have to
keep bringing it up right yeah but I
think that what I think that the great
thing for a lot of young female artists
now is that Taylor Swift built a wall
around being vague about who and what
you write about and I think that there's
a lot of other females who get to who
reap the benefits of that wall because
if if Taylor doesn't have to do it and
she can just leave crumbs and
everybody's okay with it why should they
be forced to admit anything that they're
not comfortable with and I think Taylor
built an incredible and incredible wall
for a lot of young female artists to
express themselves without being berated
as to who or why I remember interviewing
Taylor here and it was uh is it into the
woods it's kind of about Harry Styles
but it's not really sure the accident or
something like that and I remember we
were allowed to go into the room and we
could listen to the song and then I had
to do my interview on the fly like that
that's how it went yeah and I remember
asking her about it because you drop the
crumbs like it's right here like here it
is
but she was like oh no you all you get
is the crumbs yeah like that yes that's
all I'm that's you and I'm okay with
that and you now have to be okay with
that went back there back then it was
like well that's a crumb so we can open
the door and she's like nope
that but in this case she just went at
it like she's but you're probably
talking about in the interview she
probably will be like I'm not gonna go
any further because I've given you all
I'm gonna give you yeah I'm all for I'm
all for you know people putting
everything sort of out there because I
think I think especially in pop music
because I think that it's the same for a
lot of people the same five you know
songwriters and producers who are
responsible for 80 of the music that we
listen to so when you do get some sort
of like a little bit of reality of drama
of even if it is pettiness I think that
it just cuts through so well and I just
want more of well you do put crumbs in
the
and the names are not real either no
some people don't even have names
my book